an alarming spike in coronavirus cases
among children
in just the last week the u.s reported
nearly 94
000 new pediatric covet cases that's a
143 percent increase from two weeks ago
and it's the highest number of pediatric
cases reported since way back in
february
and all of it comes as a fight escalates
over republican-led efforts to ban
protective measures like mass mandates
in schools however some school districts
are defying those orders
omar villafranca is in dallas where
public schools start in less than a week
omar good morning to you what's the
situation there
good morning classes at this elementary
school actually started yesterday
here in texas governor greg abbott
signed an order
banning mass mandates across the state
but with cases on the rise and
kids under 12 ineligible to receive the
vaccine some school leaders are starting
to challenge that order
when all 145 000 dallas public school
students return to class next week
they'll be required to wear masks that's
because school superintendent michael
inohosa
issued a temporary mask mandate monday
in defiance of governor greg
abbott we're now in a dangerous
situation and so
the governor needs to run the state and
i need to run the district and as the
chief
executive officer i'm doing what i
believe is in the best interest of the
school district at this time
across texas average daily coveted cases
jumped more than 150 percent in the last
two weeks
at texas children's hospital in houston
nearly 1
000 kids have tested positive for covid
in the last week
more than 35 children are hospitalized
the most
they've treated throughout the pandemic
dr jim versalovic is the hospital's
interim pediatrician in chief
it's obviously a very tenuous time we
are
looking forward to more school districts
opening in the next two weeks
and so it's reasonable to assume that
this
wave or surge will continue in katy
texas
outside houston school officials are
complying with the governor's order
and not requiring masks in school you
guys are doing
great that's frustrated lee nelson whose
two children ashley and hope
start classes next week everybody wants
to be mask
free but we can't be until we put in the
work
especially for children we're not on an
even playing field
under 12 children are still ineligible
for vaccines
and without that children are
defenseless
nelson's youngest child 10 year old hope
is at increased risk for complications
from cobit
due to asthma and other underlying
conditions i don't want to end up
very sick i don't want to end up in the
er and i
definitely don't want to end up dead
late last night the austin school
district announced that masks
will be required at school houston isd
which is the state's largest school
district
will be voting later on this week on a
mass mandate
we reached out to texas governor greg
abbott's office but have not heard back
from them vlad
all right omar thank you very much